E
THNAACP ISERIN P
BAILIFF NECESSARY.E REPRESENTAT
TVN ONTHHO L
SPEIGH THE
ELECTION INTEGRITY BILLS.
>> THIS XAG ABOUT. JUST T -- JUS
ONL , JA D SAID YOU DON'T WANT
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUJUT ONNA
I.D.,LIEMOCRATSD IT'S
O SAOP T IDENTIOUN YOUR
RIT CAN'T
IDENTIFICATION?
Y A LOT OF Y  AND YOU'VRICHED A
LOT OF CORPORATIONS WITH
AND LI ANDONSPIRAC
THEORIES TO FOLKS WHYOU.
ASNG IS
TELLR  RIG THAT E ELECTION 0.CA?
>> THE LIE THAT IS- DEMOCRAT
R VOD.E IDEAS NS
DID DONALD LOSE THE
>>UEI DON'FETO ANYTHING TO
DECKSTEN
NOW
AT WAS THE
THAT HOST?U GE WITH AT NEED TO S
WE ARE FIGHTING FOTYPE EWS, INCI
AND WHEN THINGS LI BIGSTART TO
ANYBODY INES.
ON FOX N TRU
D ABOUT THE  VOTER
SUPPN BILL IN
>>KAALK ABOUT THBIG LIE
R RESTRICTION BILLAC COUNTRY.
THE PRESIDENT GAVE AAYE NATIONAL
NSTI
LEADERYS HISSSESSMENT OF THE
IDLISTEN
>> THIS ISEW PDEPROMISO LOWER TH
ATE,UI WEE ASLLOWIT
THAT'S T PS NOW  MAINSM E
LAWS MOU TWOMO THAPO A
SEGREGATION AND SOMEHO
AN WAR?S YOURHT H HE PRESIDENT'
BEING PASSED? MNELL IARE
WHO DENIED PRESENT
HERACK OBAMA HIS RHTL SUPREME CI
WHO ENABLE
O LIFD IS
THE O ALLOWEAN
ENCOURAGED THE KIN TOXIC
CAAS GIVEN UT LED TO THE AT OURI
ABOUT OUDEMOAC
PRDRESS.O
THOUS VOTE
ATESLIKEEEA LOT RE
BEAUIFTO DEFEAT THESPE
OF LEGISTIT TO ACT.
WE NEED LEADERS IN CONGRESS TO
ACT.
WE NEEDED THEM T
INRE
RUNNINGS TOENSURE OURUT
ARE  THA
EN ABL
EXERCISEHE G RIGHTS
ATALLO
THAT'S WHY W T
O D,ORE OUR LEADERS IN CONGRESS
TO ACT.
WILL MEET WITHATCHTING
FILIBUST R MANU THAT PUBLICLY  E
E'LL MEH  GROUP BUT OING
THE MEETING, WYOUR  WHEN YOU AL
MEETING D  ABOUT O
EXAMPLE. COLLEAGUEI HAVE  FAMIL
WEINLOES WR .E  MGUES
R WEDDING IN ORDER TO  VOTER
COMPARED TO E SACRIFICES
HA
THROUGHOUT HISTORY TT
THE SACREDO VOTE.
MANCHINT ASRATS, A MINORITY, W
HAVEN'OFNCE 19RI
LD AAJITUR SENATE AN HOL
THE GOVERN'SSIONAN
USE ERY TOOL IN OU
BRK QUORUM AND KILL THISIOBI
FOR DEMOCRACY. THAIN, THEN DEM O
YOU 'S ALR YOU'VE
SO IF YOU'RE NOR AE DOESN'WORK,U
THINK THAT YOU WIL O
W ABLE TOVINCE
E ICLY, AND THC
ARE NOG
BUSTER FOR VOTING RIGH?
BECAUSE THG.DON'T KNOWT IT'S MO
SENATOR HIN.
>> I DISE.
I OUD HOPE
E CA TACOFURS.
I HA ON THDEMOCRD REPE MN'T
I WOULDN'T HAVE EN O IEN
TALKIN RIGS,ATIONAME
EY.S HAVE JUST IN THS AND I
CONTINUE TPRR THIS EKNDTH WEEKS
>> W HFT